nancy pelosi is coming out strongly in  favor of abortion ahead of the midterms  here is a conflict within the republican  party there are those in the party that  think life begins at the candlelight  dinner the night before  and and and these people are in defiance  of that right  they're in defiance of that because  they're saying whatever they're saying  about it so that's that's what you're  seeing there but we are united in our  support for women's right to choose  okay that's a funny line these  republicans they think that life begins  you know with the candle at dinner yeah  before you go it's so crazy these crazy  republicans every sperm is sacred like  what was that monty python used to say  [Music]  republicans don't really believe that  life begins at the candle at dinner they  don't believe that life begins at the  level of the gonads or the sperm or the  egg they say that life begins at  conception